Justin Bieber has challenged Tom Cruise
to a public boat yeah like MMA alright
on Sunday Justin tweeted I want a
challenge Tom Cruise to fight in the
Octagon Tom if you don't take this fight
you're spelt wrong scared and we'll
never live it down who is willing to put
on the fight Dana White which sparked a
frenzy on social media including an
enthusiastic response from UFC champ
Conor McGregor who wrote this if Tom
Cruise is man enough to accept this
challenge McGregor sports and
entertainment will host the bout does
Cruz have the sprouts to fight like he
does in the movie stay tuned to find out
yeah now if that wasn't enough Conor up
the ante challenging Mark Wahlberg to a
fight on the very same card
oh so this is interest you know why yet
I was hoping by this time that he would
explain we would except we wouldn't know
what this sort of joke was or what the
intent was I'm not you know what I'm not
sure I and I this really came out of
nowhere because it wasn't like he was
going on a tangent about Tom Cruise all
weekend
or he had just seen a Tom Cruise film
and he was inspired it was just very
random like I don't I don't even see and
like any connection like that I don't
get
did he just decide that he wants to beat
up Tom Cruise or like I don't know I I
really don't know but which there was
something well we're waiting with bated
breath audience right now a fight to be
and also just that he's 56 what are you
doing
also he would whip you know I well
that's the thing is that Justin has he
hasn't just challenged like another
Hollywood star he's challenged the only
Hollywood star who still does all of his
own stunts
yeah and he's probably in just right
like bottom line regular shape yeah like
95 percentile and then I started to
think that maybe it was like a whole
like a battle of the religions both
hurting their churches well I'm trying
to find an answer like I'm trying to jog
a connection that would bring them
together in a way that Justin decided
one day to just say I want to fight you
so like what could you possibly be it's
funny that you say that because Paula on
Facebook says I think JB wants to show
the power of God and not the
ontology out of him lol thank which I
mean is positive Scientology body down
by the way a lot of people saying
religion I guess you I've thought that's
the first thing I thought and listen I
am no Scientologist but I will I will
back to Scientologists in this flight oh
my goodness yes I also feel a little bit
if you are a Riverdale fan out there I
feel a little bit like we've seen this
in the whole Archie
Hyrum Lodge fight from like last season
right and it didn't work out well for
Archie right yeah no that's true
and witness our colleges have not met
anot medic lorian's what is the thing
they have what is that he's because Tom
Cruise is full of them hey it's do you
know that they hook you up to the the e
meter and then they what are those
things called what do they have someone
finds something you could I know I'm
gonna get a ride on I don't mean to
disrespect but I need to know what that
is because Tom Cruise he's like a
superhuman right in that world so there
you go just we will look about that for
you we'll get back to diamonds I need to
know what that's called